I charged atmosphere in front of a
military base in yemi where hundreds of
French forces are camped Niger Security
Forces barricade the entrance denying
access to thousands of co-supporters
without access the demonstrators start
praying
came here prepared for a long wait
Mali
Mali has expelled the French they left
same in Burkina Faso why won't they
leave Niger alone I and fellow
demonstrators Will Remain here until
they leave
the Gathering is part of plans by
supporters of the Junta to pile up
Prussia on French troops to leave
religious military leaders say they
won't renew military and defense
agreement with France one of them
expires on September the 2nd and
demonstrators who support the coup have
started a sitting in front of this
military base here in Miami where an
estimated 1500 French troops are
believed to be waiting until they leave
enough the crowd here is particularly
peaked with French president Emmanuel
how can he say without friends there
will be no Malibu kinafasa and Niger
well we don't need friends to survive
but friends is desperate for our
resources the only problem we have with
the French is their selfish arrogant
leadership
a position that resonates with many
gathered here
we want that they live immediately
immediately if they don't live if they
don't believe we are we we will stay
today we will stay tomorrow and every
day
but Francis has no authority to revoke
the agreements reached nor do they have
the power to expel the French Ambassador
and troops from the country Ahmed Idris
Al Jazeera near me
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera